why
so a civil war behind us we look to the
future of Marvel explained videos and I
think that we have probably picked one
of the best characters to do a video
explanation on because Franklin Richards
is very important in the realm of Marvel
Comics not necessarily because of what
he can do and because of the vast powers
that he has or even the stories that
he's involved in but because of what he
represents but in order to make Franklin
Richards makes sense in order to
understand him as a character and his
impact on Marvel Comics we actually need
to jump back and we need to start with
some of the beginnings of comic books as
a whole and discuss how it was that
comic books came about then ultimately
the significance of Franklin Richards in
Marvel Comics so in the world of comic
books we have what's referred to as the
Golden Age of comics and the Golden Age
of comics is exactly what it sounds like
it's the importantly significant the
what many many people consider to be the
best age of comic books in the history
of all comics and the reason for this is
because the Golden Age of comics created
a lot of new standards when it came to
comic books for one it brought how many
books out of being a secondary thing
comic books for the most part didn't
really exist before the Golden Age of
comics they did to a degrees for
radically you may find comics here and
there but for the most part they existed
in the backs of published magazines they
existed in the back of newspapers and so
on they weren't really something you
could go into a store and buy the Golden
Age of comics took that element away the
Golden Age of comics took these comic
books that were in the back of magazines
and in the back of newspapers and put
them into a single publication that you
could physically go into a store and
purchase but more so than that the
Golden Age of comics created archetypes
and archetypes were the most important
thing and remain the most important
thing in the world of comics and of all
the superheroes and all these different
characters that have ever come out
of the Golden Age of comics the single
most important superhero is Superman now
I recognize a Superman is not a Marvel
comic publication but Superman's
importance in the realm of comic books
cannot be overstated and the reason why
is because Superman created the
archetype for comic-book superheroes he
was the blueprint he was the original
and virtually all other superheroes that
would ever appear in comic books
forevermore will model for the most part
the archetype that was laid down by
Superman now there are some exceptions
to this for example a name of the
Submariner and Wolverine but these
characters were designed to be anti
heroes they were designed to be
superheroes that took a different Road
they took a much darker Road and they
did less savory things but the ultimate
goal was to come about to the same end
result that your normal as Superman
archetype superheroes would do in order
to achieve that result but what we also
saw with the Golden Age of comics is
that for the most part they modeled real
world events especially when we look at
timely in Atlas comics now with regards
to timing in Atlas comics these were
comics that were under the ownership of
a man named Martin Goodman and Martin
Martin Goodman was for the most part a
marketing genius when it came to the
idea of comic-book publications
Martin Martin Goodman owned a
publication I believe called pulp comics
and pulp comics was the main umbrella it
was the main big company that he owned
in timely comics Atlas comics
and even the mud at the time the much
smaller Marvel Comics all existed as
subsidiaries of martin goodman of polk
comics but what we saw is that as time
progressed as the 30s led into the 40s
and the 40's began leading to the 50s we
saw World War 2 going on and World War
two really gave timely and Atlas comics
and even Marvel comics and identity of
sorts in the sense that they reveal to
us Captain America and Captain America
is by leaps and bounds
the most significant character that
existed in Marvel Comics or timeline
Atlas comics in the 1940s he elevated
these publications to the height of
their popularity at the time because
Captain America as we discussed in both
our Captain America video and our Bucky
Barnes video was the epitome of what it
meant to be an American he was the
epitome of what it meant
to support America he was the greatest
the single greatest piece of American
propaganda to ever come out of either of
these comic book publications but the
problem that we saw here is that once
World War two began to end once World
War two began to taper off and we moved
from World War two into the Cold War and
the conflict between the United States
and Russia and the proxy wars of the
Cold War the Korean War and the Vietnam
War and so on that Captain America lost
his identity and by virtue of Captain
America losing his identity timely in
Atlas comics didn't really have a way to
cope with this the entire basis behind
their popularity was built on a war that
is no longer going on and so what we saw
was that timely an Atlas comics began to
phase out they began to go away and that
Marvel Comics took over them entirely
but even then Marvel Comics wasn't a
wildly successful publication it was to
a degree but it was nothing like we
would see under the leadership of Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby and the Silver Age of
comics that took place in the late and
early 1950s and 1960s
so the Silver Age of comics is what I
like to refer to as the superheroes Age
of comics and the reason for this is
because while the Golden Age of comics
had introduced us to various superheroes
name of the Submariner Captain America
Superman Wonder Woman and so on the
Golden Age of comics and even the years
preceding that or coming after that
before the Silver Age of comics came in
really for the most part kept comic
books as a sort of comedic element they
just introduced a lot of funny comics
and superheroes weren't really a main
stage thing they weren't really a huge
thing they were there from time to time
especially when it came to DC Comics but
for the most part Marvel timely in Atlas
comics had maintained this comedic
element that science element and really
had left superheroes on the back burner
but then in 1960 I believe DC took a
huge risk made a big gamble and it paid
off and in response to this Marvel was
Marvel had to up their ante this
decision was DC creating a group called
the Justice League of America the
Justice League of America was a huge
action
a huge event in the world of DC and the
reason why is because as I understand it
this brought to us our very first
mainstream superhero group and comic
books and so Marvel had to respond to
this Marvel had to find some way to up
the ante and to do something that
wouldn't be viewed as a copy of the
Justice League of America and an attempt
to I guess maybe stay in the game
regarding superheroes and comics and so
in 1961 understand Lee and Jack Kirby
Marvel introduced the Fantastic Four and
this is one of the reasons why Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby and also Steve Ditko are
considered to be some of the most
important characters or some of the most
important people in the world of Marvel
Comics the reason why they're considered
so significant is because they
introduced not only some of the greatest
superheroes and greatest individuals to
have ever appeared in Marvel Comics but
also because of the stories they wrote
and the way in which they challenged the
belief systems and the more philosophies
and the viewpoints of the the people who
are reading these various comics the
Fantastic Four brought to us a superhero
family and the superhero family
functioned the exact same way you would
expect to see a family function they
bickered with one another they argue
with one another but more so than that
the comic books mirrored real-world
events when the space race was going on
between the United States and Russia we
saw this being mirrored in the the
Fantastic Four comics but as time
progressed what we saw was that Martin
Goodman who had previously owned Atlas
timely comics and at that point in time
in the 1960s Marvel Comics sold the
company for 50 million dollars to the
perfect film and Chemical Corporation
and when this purchased when the sell
was made what we saw was that a man
named Martin Ackerman had come to to the
head of the entire Marvel Corporation
but where Martin Goodman had put focus
on quality Martin Ackerman had put focus
on quantity and so what we saw going on
here was that were previously Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby we're focusing on maybe
four or five or six publications we now
saw the publication swelling and number
based on the success that we had seen
with a superhero
comic-book series in the 1960s in
addition because of the fact that there
were so many comic books being published
now it was virtually impossible for the
quality to remain there and so the
quality began to drop off and over time
we saw the saw this sort of drop-off in
marvel we eventually began to see things
shape up in such a way where quality
began to go away almost entirely we saw
that Stanley began to take the stance
where he didn't want to rock the boat
where he didn't want to challenge the
viewpoints of readers anymore and we
began to see these stories that
challenge the political and the
philosophical and the moral belief
systems of readers begin to go away and
this leads us into the discussion on
Franklin Richards to Franklin Richards
introduction in Marvel Comics and why it
is that Franklin Richards is so
important in the realm of Marvel Comics
Oh